after a month of fighting that has left
thousands dead and sent millions on the
run the war in ukraine might be entering
a new phase
kiev and its allies believe that while
russian president vladimir putin aimed
to overthrow the ukrainian government in
a lightning offensive he's actually
failed to achieve that goal the russian
army claims it will now focus on gaining
control of ukraine's eastern donbass
region but president vladimir zelinsky
says he will not give up ukrainian
territory for the sake of peace
russia says the first phase of its war
in ukraine is over
its military leaders claim the invasion
has been a success so far and its troops
will now concentrate on winning full
control of the eastern donbass region
on the whole the main objectives of the
first stage of the operation have
generally been accomplished the combat
potential of the armed forces of ukraine
has been considerably reduced which
makes it possible to focus on the main
efforts to achieve the main goal
liberation of donbass
at the beginning of russia's invasion
president vladimir putin kept his
initial objectives vague
western and ukrainian intelligence said
the aim was to topple ukraine's elected
government and install a puppet regime
in kiev
but moscow has faced stiffer resistance
than anticipated
so russia has relied on artillery and
airstrikes bombarding cities and urban
areas from afar
in the north east ukraine's second
largest city harkev still stands
but a month of constant shelling has
left many buildings destroyed
and in donbass the besieged port of
mariopol has endured the worst of
russia's bombardment
those that have managed to escape tell
of a city in ruins
there are no roads hospitals shops or
factories anymore people have no money
mario poll almost doesn't exist anymore
all that is left of it is a name on the
map a few houses
and our memories
as russia says it's refocusing on
donbass it is uncertain what this new
phase of the conflict will look like
president zielenski asserted that heavy
russian losses have forced the kremlin
to reassess its goals and take peace
negotiations more seriously
but with putin's original objective
seemingly thwarted western leaders also
fear he may resort to more extreme
measures
including the use of chemical weapons
for more let's bring in dw correspondent
nick connolly who's in the ukrainian
capital kiev
russia seemingly shifting its focus
we're seeing it rejigging its goals in
this war
how is this russian army statement being
received where you are
with a lot of skepticism is the short
answer um i think there is a
considerable um doubt as to whether
russia really did yes have a kind of
fixed goal whether this was more just an
opportunistic attack on ukraine an
attempt to see how ukraine would stand
up to a concerted pressure but
definitely in the first few days and
weeks of this invasion the rhetoric kind
of coming out of moscow was totally
different they were talking about
so-called denatification of ukraine and
its democratically elected government
they were talking about full
demilitarization which sounded like they
wanted to basically uh keep ukraine
without an army forever um definitely
the rhetoric is being dialed down but
there's definitely the sense here in
ukraine that this is tactic this is
about winning time russia's having
significant problems with its logistics
and supplying its troops here so maybe
to win time to be able to then actually
continue that offensive not just in
donbass but across the country
and definitely when you look at russian
state media there was a seemingly huge
appetite for ukraine basically under
full russian control so there's still no
real sense here that this is over that
russia is only going to focus in the
east but this is just also for russian
domestic consumption for the russian
government to show its people some kind
of success and say here is a manageable
goal here is something we can achieve in
the short to medium term rather than
this being the fiasco that lots of
western experts are calling it
now russia is sort of putting this in
phases talking about one phase that's
just ended another one in donbass where
does kiev fit in these phases
that's not quite clear i think people
here you know about half the population
is
estimated still to be here two million
people if you believe the statistics and
they've been living now for the last few
weeks with the constant threat uh of a
russian um
attack on the capital itself or an
attempt to storm the capital um every
couple of days there's news that in two
three days there's a russian attack
expected that hasn't happened uh the
russians have come up against a lot
stiffer resistance they were expecting
and in the east of the city on the other
side of the river uh there are reports
that the russian forces have been
actually being pushed back by about
20-30 kilometers in the west about 20
kilometers behind me uh they are
basically stuck and now if you believe
the ukrainian military sources uh
under threat of being surrounded so
there's definitely no sense that they
are making progress on the ground but
they are definitely shelling more
they're using more rockets and
especially yesterday we had basically a
whole afternoon with just endless air
raid warnings and lots of pretty big
bangs seemingly quite close to the
center so a sense that while they're
getting stuck on the ground they're now
using the same kind of increasingly
using the kind of tactics they've used
in kharkiv a maripole of using more
artillery more in the way of missiles to
reach areas they're not getting to on
the ground
and looking at president zielenski of of
ukraine would there be any change in the
way he views the independence or the of
the self-proclaimed republics of donetsk
and luhansk
i think that's definitely a red line
we've heard that from him the same goes
for recognizing russian control of annex
crimea there had been some news
yesterday from turkey where president
erdogan or at least sources close to him
had claimed that there was some growing
closeness oh and willingness to make
compromises there between ukraine and
russia that was then uh ruled out and uh
in pretty clear terms by ukraine's
foreign minister i think the only place
where there is some potential for uh
concessions for uh getting closer is on
nato there have been signals from the
ukrainian government they might be
willing to give up on that aspiration to
join nato uh the eu membership is still
very much on the cards but for now it
doesn't seem like either side really is
willing to give up and to sign up to
painful compromises ukraine definitely
is doing better than anyone had expected
at least even maybe some ukrainians and
a desire to stick this out and to really
force russia to give peace terms that
are acceptable to most ukrainians after
a month of war and lots of dead
all right dw correspondent nick connolly
in kiev many thanks
you can now speak to ben hodges a
retired u.s lieutenant general and
former commander of the u.s army in
europe who's joining us
from doha welcome to dw general now the
uh russian military making this uh
statement apparently shifting its focus
uh from the kiev offensive and now to
liberating as it says don bass what do
you make of that
this is a colossal failure
by the russian federation armed forces
and
of course they're going to try and dress
it up as something else that they've
accomplished everything they meant to
but they haven't accomplished anything
except demonstrate
that their military
has suffered from decades of corruption
inside the ministry of defense and
inside the army and they've demonstrated
that
ukrainians have something to fight for
where russian soldiers don't so
i would say this clearly is the
culmination of russia's ability to
launch
or conduct sustained offensive
operations large-scale unfortunately
they still have the ability to murder uh
innocent ukrainians
what do you expect from the russian
forces around kiev now those talk of the
long convoy of vehicles approaching the
city and and all these other forces what
kind of campaign will they be carrying
out right now
i think what we're going to see is a an
attempt by the russian forces to harden
what they have so you'll start seeing
reports of digging in and fortifications
uh to make it difficult for ukraine to
to push them out if ukraine is able to
launch a counter offensive and this
would be done in my view to um
to create new facts on the ground
for negotiation
to create a new sort of frozen conflict
uh and of course this is what we we
cannot afford we should not allow um
allow russia to be rewarded for their uh
attack on ukraine
we we the west need to be talking about
uh
this is democracy
versus autocracy and so we should be
pouring in support for ukraine so that
they can in fact push russian forces
back to the pre-24 february line
um
lots of sources uh are talking about
the russians suffering massive
casualties you mentioned that the
russians have had a failure there but
we're hearing estimates of between seven
and fifteen thousand troops killed in
action how reliable are these figures
well i'm always suspicious uh when
somebody makes an estimate
like that from seven to fifteen thousand
i mean that's a that that's a heck of a
range for estimates
um
i generally tend to uh stay away from
body counts because there's so many
reasons why they are seldom accurate
unless you actually see the
dead soldiers so
i would generally go with the lower
estimate
but then you have to also assume that
anywhere from two to three times as many
have been wounded that's kind of the
standard
conversion factor if you will if you're
trying to estimate
damage to the opposing force
so however many russian soldiers have
been killed
even at the low estimate that is a
staggering number of casualties
in just four to five weeks of war time
and it will be impossible for the
kremlin to hide this from the russian
population the way they've tried to in
the past
now ukraine is pushing for a no-fly zone
now general you have signed a letter
backing that but doesn't that open a can
of worms uh for us to then see
a direct con confrontation between nato
and russia
you know i did sign that letter and i
would sign it again
even though there is risk exactly as you
point out
the direct confrontation that could
result of nato aircraft in the sky
versus russian aircraft
but look
many people will remember srebanitza
july 1995 where uh soldiers stayed
outside the city under the u.n mandate
while uh republican serps forces
murdered 8 000 bosnian men and boys and
it feels a little bit to me like we're
not doing enough to help prevent the
murder of ukrainian citizens and so yes
of course there's risk with a with a
no-fly zone but i think there's a way to
do it first of all we have massive
advantages over the russians if you put
together the combined military economy
and population of the 30 nations of nato
versus russia i mean it's a staggering
uh advantage that we have and so we
should we could do this by communicating
to the russians that look if one russian
airplane comes up it will be destroyed
immediately and then we will go after
other things so communicating this very
clearly is a way to do this to allow the
evacuation of people out of cities like
mariopol
yes of course there's risk but if even
if i was still the commander today i
would absolutely be advocating um for
this
now general very briefly um i know this
is a difficult one but how long do you
see this conflict continuing and what
kind of outcome do you expect
i think it depends on us the west
if we
do not ramp up the support
for ukraine like like the berlin airlift
i mean that sort of sense of urgency if
we don't do that then russia is going to
be able to sit there and continue to
kill ukrainians they may not take any
more territory in fact i'm sure they
won't take any more territory but they
will continue to destroy ukraine and
that's why we have got to do a lot more
okay
retired lieutenant general ben hodges
many thanks for speaking to us
thanks for the privilege
let's take a look now at some other
developments in the war
french president emmanuel macron has
proposed an international mission to
evacuate people from mariopol the
ukrainian city devastated by russian
attacks macron said he was working on a
humanitarian
operation together with turkey and
greece and he would soon call russian
president vladimir putin to work out the
details
more than 130 refugees from ukraine have
arrived in germany from moldova hundreds
of thousands of ukrainians have fled to
the small former soviet republic
germany plans to airlift 2500 refugees
out of moldova to help a deal with the
influx
pope francis has led a ceremony at the
vatican to consecrate both russia and
ukraine to the immaculate heart of the
virgin mary the prayer ritual is of deep
spiritual importance to many catholics
the service was francis's latest effort
for peace in what he has called a cruel
and senseless war
the eu has signed a deal with the u.s to
help secure more natural gas and wean
itself off russian imports it's one of
many steps now being taken in the eu to
cut economic ties with moscow but
experts believe it'll take years to
build an energy infrastructure that does
not rely on russian energy supplies
pipelines still bringing russian gas
into the eu
around 40 percent of europe's gas
consumption comes from russia which is
why eu leaders haven't been able to
agree a ban on imports as a way of
trying to force moscow to end the war in
ukraine
but what they did do at a summit in
brussels attended by president biden is
agree a deal to buy more gas from the us
we need to work toward developing
infrastructure which will allow us a
greater capacity to move gas where we
need it
that means we have taken a conscious
decision to better connect national
networks
the plan is to increase imports from
america by an additional 15 billion
cubic meters this year with an aim to
increasing that to 50 billion per year
in the coming years currently eu imports
from america stand at 22 billion cubic
meters annually the eu's annual
dependence on russia is a hundred and
fifty billion cubic meters though so the
increases from the us won't be enough to
plug the gap
i know i know that eliminating russian
gas will have costs for europe
but it's not only the right thing to do
from a moral standpoint
it's going to put us on a much stronger
strategic footing
what isn't clear from the statement is
how much more expensive the gas coming
from the u.s will be for europe or how
shipping ports which are already nearly
at capacity for importing gas will be
expanded
liquefied natural gas doesn't just flow
through pipelines like russian gas does
there's the well in america you take a
bucket um of a gas out
liquefy it put it on a ship send it
across the atlantic it goes into an
import terminal which will take that
liquid gas turn it back into gaseous gas
and then it goes into the domestic
pipeline infrastructure and is used
exactly the same way that the russian
would be but there are all those steps
following the agreement with the u.s eu
leaders continued their summit and hit a
major friction point over whether
government should now be allowed to
intervene in the markets to cap energy
prices which are soaring for their
citizens dw correspondent simon young
sent us his assessment of the deal
between the eu and the us
well this is all part of a a shift away
from dependence on russian energy
sources we've seen the german economy
minister robert harbeck going to the
gulf to sign deals with countries there
on energy supply
and he's also saying by the way that
reliance on
russian coal will come down by half in
the next few weeks and he expects a
reliance on russian energy uh russian
oil excuse me from germany uh to uh
be
you know virtually ended by the middle
of 2024 so you're seeing all these kind
of positive signals uh people saying we
can do without rushing russian oil and
gas when we need to
dw political correspondent simon young
now ukraine's neighbor slovakia has been
one of the countries most affected by
russia's war dw's christine mundo spoke
to prime minister eduard hegar at the eu
summit he told her that europe should
avoid damaging its own economy as it
targets russian president vladimir putin
with sanctions
we want him to fail
and we have to see what makes him to
fail because if we disconnect
immediately this day we disconnect
how much
how long can we
survive without gas and oil
because if we cannot survive if the
european economy the society will
collapse then he won
putin would won would win
we don't want him to win
so and we see that the storage
of our capacity is very little
unfortunately we weren't prepared for
that as well so we have to do we have to
use those tools that will harm him
because if we use a tool that we think
will harm him but actually will harm us
much more we lose and he wins and we
don't want that right okay but you are
discussing as the block
a fifth round of sanctions
what then do you put into those
sanctions
that that hurts him
well the variety is still there and uh
that was the discussion that that's why
our conclusions because as you know we
don't uh
decide on particular the sanctions we
decide that we must be robust that must
be growing we're escalating the
sanctions and then the commission
develops exact precise sanctions we we
also said we have to be very
uh i would say precise on on the
loopholes on really getting and catching
the the property of the oligarchs
because they they're the ones who are
closest to vladimir putin they're the
ones who can influence him so if we
catch their uh their property and we
know that this is not the money that
they earn earned
legally i mean they are occupying their
own people so we must collect uh this
property everywhere where it is it's not
as easy but it's happening and we must
be more active on this and or precise
and that's what's happening and this
could uh increase the pressure and we're
looking for freezing the assets and
we're dealing with other
ideas that we have on the table and
commission will be publishing them as as
they come on understood slovakia is also
a nato member we heard from the
secretary-general of nato saying that if
chemical weapons or nuclear weapons were
to be used that completely changes the
game
from where you stand
prime minister
if that were to happen
what reaction
does nato how does nato need to respond
well first of all we have to prevent
that we have to do everything to prevent
it and i think uh by what we do that
we're enforcing the eastern flank with
the soldiers with the equipment showing
that
this is not the right way to do nobody
of us wants the third world war we we
are the community of peace that's what
we're saying and we're saying this also
to putin stop the aggression we want
peace we don't think that killing people
is right in the 21st century so so of
course if he will escalate it which i
don't think he will he's just he's just
uh
playing with the people he wants to he
wants to make a fear of the people
excuse me now of europe so and we that's
why we have to be sovereign we have to
be
bold and tell him enough is enough and
we will crush you economically my final
question slovakia
has now become home to thousands i
imagine of ukrainian mostly women
children and the elderly um can you just
talk to us about that humanitarian
effort
have you engaged some of those refugees
absolutely i mean i've been going to the
border uh every three days because uh
it's important that we provide them a
warm welcome and i'm very thankful to
also our citizens that they're providing
we're welcome we have a lot of
volunteers who came and helping and we
hear the stories of the women and the
children sometimes they don't even pack
sometimes the children don't have even
even shoes because they pack so quickly
and to try to leave from the war and
they they are very thankful they say why
are you doing it why is so nice to us
and they say because you're our
neighbors you're our friends and there
is a terrible war so they appreciate it
very much we introduced several programs
on providing them work if they wish
providing them kindergarten and school
for the kids uh providing them housing
of course also food so and we'll be
developing it so they can temporarily
stay as long as they need and they were
wanting to go back as soon as possible
but now they have to stay in a safe
environment in europe
prime minister we appreciate your time
thank you so much for that thank you
very much
meanwhile u.s president joe biden is in
the polish capital warsaw in a show of
support for his nato ally the visit
comes after he announced a new energy
deal with the eu aimed at replacing some
of the russian gas supply to the block
earlier biden traveled to the ukrainian
border where he met polish president
anja duda in the southeastern city of
jeju
where the u.s military is supporting
polish troops as part of nato now biden
is to hold more talks with duda this
weekend on the west's military
humanitarian and economic response to
russia's war on ukraine
now speaking at a briefing with
president duda and military officials by
the most clear about what he thinks is
the way forward
the single most important thing
that
we can do from the outset
is keep
the democracies united
in our opposition and our
effort to
curtail
the devastation
that is occurring at the hands of a man
who
i quite frankly think is a war criminal
and and i think it will meet the legal
definition of that as well
dw's barbara vezel expel explained what
signal biden is hoping to send with his
visit
the message is absolutely clear he has
particularly by traveling to the border
region with ukraine
sent the message to president putin
that the nato alliance is ready to
defend every
foot of their territory
that was something that the nato leaders
reiterated when they met in brussels on
thursday and that is the main message of
president biden here he says
around 10 000
u.s soldiers are stationed in poland and
this town your trophy that he visited
today has about a thousand seven hundred
of them and he sat down with them to
have a slice of pizza as american
presidents tend to do when they visit
their troops and he said we're very
grateful for your service and it is very
important
to defend
the borders here and defend the nato
alliance and
show
moscow that they can't advance any
further so that is the strategic aim
really of this visit here
dw's barbara basil in warsaw
refugees from ukraine have been crossing
into neighboring countries ever since
russia invaded more than half a million
people have fled to safety in romania
it's the second most frequent
destination after poland
many arrive with harrowing tales of
their escape from war
it's just a short ride to safety but for
many here it comes after a long and
perilous journey
this family reunited at the docks some
came by ferry others over land leaving
behind a home caught in some of the
fiercest fighting so far
the situation is very bad
it is being shelled from every direction
people who are able to flee are fleeing
it is hard i want to go home
i want to go home very much
ukraine's short border with romania runs
along the danube river ferries land at
the town of visaca with only a few
thousand inhabitants it has become yet
another transit point as refugees flow
out of ukraine
many of the new arrivals are fleeing
southern ukraine where the russians have
been attacking cities like mikolive near
the black sea coast and moving towards
the major port city of odessa
i could have never believed in such
things before
honestly this is a shock we could have
never believed that the sky would have
been so dangerous
that we'd be afraid of airplanes and
other things
i didn't expect any of this
every day there is death there's
destruction
so to be there is very scary especially
with small children
that's why we left
we first went to odessa
stayed there for one night
but there are air raid sirens every day
destruction shots fired the whole
package
[Music]
the red cross has set up tents to
welcome the ukrainians but these tents
and this town are just another transit
point for those arriving their journey
is far from over
a ukrainian runner who fled her country
last month has won the jerusalem
marathon valentina veretzka left ukraine
with her 11 year old daughter while her
husband who's also her coach stayed
behind she told dw that fans back home
had urged her to run for peace
just a few weeks ago valentina veretzka
was fleeing for her life
now the ukrainian marathon runner is
trying to promote peace around the world
starting with the jerusalem marathon
before the race she told dw about the
support she still has back home
i have a lot of message from
ukraine kids you know
from ukraine athletes
from a lot of from a lot of people from
ukraine for
you know they wish
peace and they very wish i'm
speak here about peace
it was unusually wet and cold for the
start of the jerusalem race but after
the journey she has been on she just
felt relief to be running again the race
was a mixed event so she cleverly used
male runners as pacesetters in a bid to
be the first woman to cross the line
she achieved her goal and celebrated
with the israeli and ukrainian flags
she hopes to soon be reunited with her
husband who is also her coach but has
remained in ukraine after the russian
invasion
she vowed to do even better in the race
next year
is it difficult today
but the time is perfect and i
next year when i will come with my
husband we break this record and
usually martin have new records but 20
23 i promise
it is a medal that means so much after a
terrible month for her family
she's yet another ukrainian sports star
doing incredible things in the face of
adversity
you